la lumière se sent ici comme chez elle
le polissage de chacun des triangles qui
composent son enveloppe a été
spécialement réalisé en fonction de sa
position par rapport au soleil de sorte
qu'une hirondelle en plein vol peut
admirer son reflet dans l'un des miroirs
sans qu aucune des formations de l'alter
promenade à la ville est ce un livre un
regard de l'écrivain jean rouaud sur la
cité des sciences le résultat de ces des
ondulations au hasard entre deux portes
de paris pantin et la ville est son
ancien quartier qui m'intéressent là
c'est vraiment la question du sens c'est
comme une cathédrale éclatez vous avez
le corps positiviste des sciences de la
terre vraiment ensuite vous avez la
magie haute et l'univers et qui lucienne
et puis à l'autre bout vous avez la cité
de la musique avec ses vagues
ondulatoire cette architecture de france
en pas comme ça ondulatoire qui se
charge en fait de reggae la terre et le
ciel
et c'est devant buzz réjean vous aulas
confère un poids un endroit où là encore
la nature a été domestiqué
on est dans un simulacre de la nature on
nous le rappelle on sait pas l'illusion
absolue où on pourrait s'y croire donc
on ne suivra pas parce qu'elle est une
chose qui nous rappelle que nous sommes
dans ce noeud dans une cité une cité qui
renferme également son cimetière celui
de l'ère industrielle et de la société
de consommation
la bicyclette géantes c'est comme ceux
de 7,7 fantasmatique de la science qui
qui qui compte le tout aux hormones
enfin vraiment le les lapins géants
c'est alors c'est à la fois alice mais
c'est aussi du l'hiver ça rejoint une
des fantasmes at il très anciennes comme
ça d'après le prix goncourt ce temple de
la science des rattrapé par la mystique
et la superstition vraiment témoignent
ces quelques pièces jeté là comme pour
conjurer le sort à travers cette lecture
du site il ya cette presque cette
fatalité humaine comme ça comme quoi on
n'échappe pas à cette pesanteur de
l'esprit humain qui est toujours en
recherche qui a toujours peur qui veut
toujours se préserver et qui est
toujours taraudé par les grandes
questions quoi